hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and I'm Cody Meltzer and this is terras
just suck there's so many cameras oh
this is pepper just suck and Cody also
just saw two as well
hauntingly who we just saw Eddie Bell
creation so we were driving home and I
was saying like I need to figure out
some things that I didn't like about it
because I'm not a critic and when I go
into a movie that I'm like really stoked
for I am NOT looking for criticism I am
looking to have a good time and so then
after like these videos come out people
and like alter you but like my critiques
of the film I'm like oh that's true but
I can't guys I'm not a critic and I love
horror and I've been stoked for this and
I enjoyed it I thought this was a great
fourth edition to be conjuring kind of
world the whole time I was enjoying the
film but I was worried that they weren't
going to tie in the first Annabelle and
and it was revealed that they do when
it's like really killer and awesome and
I love like a mostly female cast and I
was into it and I have two criticisms of
the film's for me for anybody follows
him around social media or watch the
last video Mike my concern was Annihilus
I don't like horror it's that like the
like jump scary like when I saw the
remake of the omen that kind of stuff
just gets get on like I just like I live
alone and it just really gets under my
skin I would be the kid in a horror
movie you wouldn't believe and I'd be
like no there are demons and like sure
Bobby I don't know it might be that I
don't know why you call but you would be
nice do I believe me I don't even
believe in your name yeah but I mean
like I did enjoy the lower aspect of it
which is one thing I really do enjoy in
horror movies like that's one of the
things I like about horror movies I
liked a lot of you know the
cinematography was good the direction
seems adequate casting
strong tell us what you didn't like
hahaha
Oh gonna let you talk around was your
life I do agree the junk scare horror is
not the strongest of the genre I was
just talking to a friend
wait before you continue let me just
close this medicine cabinet mirror and
oh my god oh oh so the thing is a hiding
to me will continue but the door just
shut agreed agreed
I was talking to a friend before this
and he was like I dig horror films but
it's difficult to find a good one which
I completely agree with a Couture he
said mr. J Jarvie hello he said that
horror is a genre that you just want
more content so the audience is more
forgiving because you're just welcoming
that sweet sweet content give me give me
the jump scare thing really started with
like the remake of The Omen those kind
of movies now they were like just to
remake and these four movies I will
say do have jump scares for short but
the stories are more solid specially
conjuring and conjuring 2 and then um
and all came out I saw Annabelle and was
underwhelmed but this made up for it for
me I thought that it was definitely
scary in some cool moments definitely
there were jump scares but I didn't hate
them story-wise there were a couple
holes like why would these humans bring
in this whole cart of women to look out
parts of women when they know that
there's an evil spirit looking to devour
women's souls that were maybe on them
that's a very bad but I did all I still
really I really enjoyed it
so movie has three main components
Catholics children and a will and that's
a recurring theme in horror like
seriously strong am diesel horror like
you know well Catholic blessing a house
or a jewelry are they all right but
that's my thing it's like so that's the
thing where I'm like I don't know if
that's a problem I have like I don't
know if I appreciate the fact that
kind of a throwback to like a long
lineage of horror tropes or if I'm like
all right we get it
Catholic swells and children are a bad
scene when it comes to demons but like
can we can we freshen that up a little
bit you know the well was super
unnecessary they could have cut the well
and it would have been like all right
one right cliche I agree with you but I
would argue that the Catholicism which
is in every flippin horror film but I
would argue it's because they've got the
long history of exorcisms but I
understand I mean like it'd be nice if
we could throw some Pentecostals is
something even a couple whole speaking
in tongues yeah we Scientology are
exploited yeah we're like that is let's
joke I made leaving the theaters like
where's like the barren Hindu couple
that lives in a desert my major my major
problem was filmed specifically outside
of anything else is as somebody who was
like going in like and kind of II know I
freaked out for a lot of the movies uh
anytime they actually showed the demon I
immediately was taken out of it like I I
complete especially it's like the face
of the demon
yeah it completely removed fear from me
totally like I just suddenly wasn't like
I what I must laugh at the doorman
watching more of like a comic book
that's done bad yeah we are like a
cartoon animation and I will say that
that is totally a runnin thing with the
Pacific and conjuring - they show a
full-on giant demon named Hector I we
joked that it was alec baldwin because
his name Valek i don't know it sounded
very much like Alec so Alec Baldwin
people always really want to see them I
do yeah yeah I always want to see it
especially gonna be like slasher or it's
like because you imagine Friday the 13th
of Halloween or you know member Brown
Elm Street okay can you imagine
Nightmare Before grizzled you didn't
suggest Ellington there were moments
when it was a lot less about the story
and more about just like scaring you so
very long drawn-out moments of like
weird items in the house breaking anyway
weird this is a house full of people who
can who do not hear screaming when
they're sleeping
yeah we're officially in horror films
especially in like hundred one and two
I'm like just get out of the house
please yeah lead the house that these
women have nowhere to go
it's so far out there and it's very
clear that it's the property and not
just the house itself and obviously
obviously the whole thing once you know
that it's like it I know it's a
traveling
yeah the travel is children yeah you
know it's got a suitcase ready to go
character exploration would have been
more interesting especially in the
little lesbian love interest oh I am
relatively certain that this was a kind
of an understory about lesbian interest
in the 1950s I also really appreciated
because of fanservice I really did
appreciate that the movie opened on
cameras home a little bit opens on
cameras child at home and and we see her
father working on dolls and he comes
into the house and it was really nice to
know that they understood how big of a
bad camera was and decided to make it
about her family and over it I was like
this was like exactly where I grew up
and he leaned over it was like I was
legit he's just going to make a joke
about that I didn't know where you grew
up so yeah I do every scene where she
grew up definitely in California yeah so
where where I grow so that was nice that
was a nice add on his movie had a lot of
like great like lore a lot of interest
but it also has like a lot of downtime
and then just a lot of time being like
like being spent where we're just like
oh god what's going to happen I do
really enjoy being scared
it's like my favorite emotion as I
really enjoy the parts where you're like
waiting they're like oh god what's going
to happen oh my god we go oh my god I
felt like there was more suspenseful
like that kind of suspension suspenseful
moments building up to like a kind of
scary moment your horse is being like
wow like freaked out just random sudden
yeah yeah it was working things there
were jump scares for sure but it was it
was more worked out through the music
and less sort of music through those
things but then less about like you know
like a face in a mirror there were no
nearer moments which we talked about
before yeah really excited about the
lack of mirrors I I think as somebody
who goes to every scary movie that comes
out in theatres I thought it was solid
comparatively two things that have come
out widespread in theaters for like for
not like festival things that are
probably better than widespread feeder
releases but still like for for a
theater release I thought this was a
really decent horror film
I've definitely a decent fourth film of
like a whole kind of conjuring series
again I was really delighted at the end
how they tied in Annabelle to Annabelle
creation episode yeah in terms of a
horror movie this wasn't the emoji movie
which was a far scarier movie ah thank
you for facing some mad fears and doing
this with me can you show them the know
French art agree the whole time a
religiously Rosanna providing this and
then for the really scary parts I would
reach over his head it everyone's gonna
make fun of me cool not a bit I brought
my little show about my little
tardigrade I have a bigger one but I
thought they'd be weird if I brought
that in the theater it would have so I
brought my for the record it was very I
brought the travel one he's a tardigrade
he can survive everything and so can I
if I hold it tightly to my chest
[Music]